for millions of people in china there's
only one way to book a cab
using the smartphone app known locally
as dd but the app has become the latest
target of a chinese government crackdown
on technology companies the country's
cyberspace regulator says dd violated
personal data laws
and chinese app stores have been ordered
to remove it the announcement came days
after parent company dd global listed
shares on the new york stock exchange
the second largest initial public
offering by a chinese company in the us
it's big it's bigger than uber
it's one of a dominant player
and it looks like the valuation that was
placed on the company was reasonable i
think investors are a little worried
about regulatory crackdowns
the company raised almost 4.5 billion
dollars on wednesday
but the share price has since dropped dd
operates in china
and in more than 15 other countries
existing users can continue to use the
app
so far beijing has been clamping down on
technology companies
over anti-trust and data security
concerns
last october regulators quashed the
public share offering of ant financial
the largest financial technology company
in the world
in april ads parent company alibaba was
fined a record 2.8 billion dollars for
anti-trust violations
the moves have been seen as the chinese
government's effort to rein in the power
and influence of founder jack
ma who openly criticized beijing's
economic policies
describing them as restrictive the
billionaire entrepreneur has retired
from running the companies he started
and for months has practically
disappeared from public view
the crackdowns follow a period of
unfettered growth for china's technology
industry
and it has investors increasingly
worried about the risk of getting on the
wrong side
of the chinese government authorities
say the moves are necessary for reducing
risks and protecting consumers
supporters have compared them to efforts
to regulate technology giants facebook
and google
in the us and europe china is moving
from being one of the least regulated
cyberspace countries in the world to one
of the
most not just the most regulated and
probably the most
effectively regulated dd says it's
working with the government to address
its concerns
and will listen to its guidance whether
or not the move is about
tightening policy or controlling power
the tech giant has little choice but to
comply
katrina you al jazeera beijing